bonjour à tous alors une fois n'est pas
coutume on se retrouve aujourd'hui en
extérieur parce qu'il faut parfois à
changer les habitudes
d'autant que c'est le thème de cette
vidéo
figurez vous que j'ai repris le sport
alors si vous en foutez mer voilà j'ai
repris le sport est comme le sait toute
personne qui fait du sport
à la reprise elle est toujours un petit
peu difficile
elle est toujours un petit peu
douloureuse les contraignantes
on décide de se remettre au sport
seulement voilà bah on a la flemme
on est fatigué on a mieux à faire
on est très bon quand il s'agit de se
trouver des excuses pour éviter les
forts mais bon on s'est dit qu'on ci
remettait donc on s'y remet et puis
finalement au bout de la première séance
on sent bien et on est content on se dit
qu'on a bien fait de reprendre le
lendemain on a encore un peu la flemme
on n'est pas hyper enthousiaste mais bon
on a entamé un nouveau cycle
donc là on le fait au bout de la
deuxième séance
on commence à apprécier lendemain on a
une attitude un peu plus neutre n'est
pas super enthousiaste mais ce n'est
plus une contrainte
donc on le fait et plus les jours
passent et plus on finit par prendre du
plaisir
plus on finit même par
avoir envie et être impatient de pouvoir
faire notre sens les jours qu'on
consacre au repos parfois nous
paraissent un petit peu long un peu
frustrant donc même si c'est jour de
repos ben on fait une petite séance
qu'est ce que je veux dire par là c'est
bien je veux dire que l' envie n'est de
l'habitude et que l'habitude à un
pouvoir absolument incroyable alors
c'est que c'est quelque chose que vous
avez déjà entendu c'est le genre de
paroles qu'on entend beaucoup chez lé
coach en développement personnel
mais vous allez voir que si on creuse un
petit peu derrière ce concept d'habitude
philosophiquement on va trouver des
choses des choses intéressantes à
comprendre parce que ce sont des choses
utiles alors saint-augustin disait que
l'habitude était comme une seconde
nature
c'est très fort comme formule une
seconde nature
on voit à peu près ce que signifie avoir
une nature
chacun a par rapport à son caractère
pourra se dire de temps en temps c'est
ma nature je suis né comme ça
la nature pour nous c'est ce qui est
innée tandis que l'habitude c'est
quelque chose qu'on acquiert dans le
temps c'est quelque chose de contingents
c'est à dire c'est quelque chose on peut
très bien passer sa vie à ne pas mettre
en place par exemple ont l'habitude de
se coucher tôt c'est très difficile
quand on est un couche tard de prendre
l'habitude de se coucher tôt
on a l'impression qu'on perd une grande
partie de notre vie nous sommes des
êtres d'habitude l'habitude d'une
certaine manière nous façonnent elle
fait de nous ce que nous sommes au
quotidien les bonnes habitudes
elle nous porte elles nous rendent
efficace il n'y a qu'à voir les sportifs
qui sont des êtres d'habitude
prenez l'exemple des joueurs de tennis
c'est assez frappant chez eux
la manière dont le joueur rejoint sa
chaise entre deux manches la manière
dont il déplie sa serviette
donc il boit dans sa bouteille d'eau
tout est maîtrisé
tout est répétitif mécanique parce que
la ritualisation permet le maintien de
la concentration la ritualisation c'est
le fait de se rassurer par des gestes
qui se répètent et qui nous permettent
de maîtriser notre environnement qui
nous permet de nous sentir en sécurité
la peur de l'inconnu
la peur de l'altérité la peur de ce qui
sort de l'habitude nous prouve que nous
sommes des êtres d'habitude que nous
avons besoin de répétitions alors je
disais que les bonnes habitudes nous
porte et elle nous élève évidemment
linverse les mauvaises habitudes
eh bien elles peuvent nous détruire
elles peuvent nous emprisonner nous
posséder
mais l'erreur consisterait à croire que
nous sommes forcés à rester prisonnier
nos mauvaises habitudes parce qu'après
tout l'habitude c'est nous qui la créons
donc à partir du moment où nous sommes
enfermés dans une mauvaise habitude il
ne tient qu'à nous de rechange et
l'habitude c'est le pouvoir qu'a l'homme
d'influencé son destin tous les
entrepreneurs tous les grands artistes
volet sportif vous diront à quel point
il est nécessaire de s'autodiscipliner
et de s'imposer une routine de travail
le mythe de l'écrivain touché par la
grâce de l'inspiration qui se mettraient
à écrire par fulgurances de temps en
temps ça n'existe pas écrivain connaît
la pénibilité de l'effort de se mettre
au travail tous les matins et de passer
ces sept ou huit heures devant son écran
devant son clavier
parce qu'il sait que c'est à cette seule
condition que quelque chose pour à
jaillir de son esprit l'esprit comme le
corps a besoin d'habitude
pour atteindre ces objectifs il faut
créer de bonnes habitudes
celui qui a un mode de vie absolument
dissolue celui qui ne s'inflige pas
l'autodiscipline minimale pour remplir
ses objectifs bien celui là se condamne
à échoué d'une manière ou d'une autre
donc l'habitude n'est ni mauvaise ni
bonne en soi
dire qu'on n'aime pas l'habitude qu'on
n'aime pas la routine ça ne veut rien
dire en réalité mais parce que si vous
faites la fête tous les soirs jusqu'à 6h
du matin vous êtes aussi dans la routine
vous êtes dans votre routine dans votre
habitude et cette habitude là ne vaut
pas mieux qu'une autre
la routine donne des repères des repères
stables l'habitude d'une certaine
manière c'est plus fort que l'an viii
parce que l' envie
elle est volatile en vie elle peut s'en
aller comme elle est venue alors que
l'habitude elle est durable
c'est justement ce qui la définit elle
est stable dans le temps elle est solide
l'habitude est une seconde nature
on pourrait dire que ce n'est pas tant
nous qui créons nos habitudes que nos
habitudes qui nous crée des habitudes
disait fond de nous ce que nous sommes
et l'avantagé c'est que c'est nous qui
décidons de nos habitudes si nous qui
décidons de mettre en place des repères
que nous allons répéter
de telle sorte qu'au bout d'un moment ce
ne sera plus un effort l'habitude à cet
effet de normaliser ce qui peut nous
paraître contraignant fatiguant
éprouvant l'habitude normalise nos
efforts vous remarquerez que bien
souvent ce qui nous empêche de réussir
ce qui nous empêche d'accomplir une
tâche
c'est moins le travail que cette tâche
réclame que notre des motivations a
priori vis-à-vis de cet effort comme si
c'était notre projection de l'effort qui
nous empêchait d'accomplir ce que nous
avons à accomplir
c'est très mental tout ça c'est très
mental et beaucoup de choses dans la
matière sont liées au mental
on entend souvent dire qu'il faut perdre
ses mauvaises habitudes
c'est vrai seulement une habitude qui
disparaît et remplacée par une autre
parce que l'être humain a besoin
d'habitude
donc je dirais qu'il ne faut pas
seulement perdre ses mauvaises habitudes
il faudrait plutôt les remplacer par
d'autres
par exemple on ne se dira pas qu'il faut
arrêter de fumer
il faut perdre cette mauvaise habitude
on se dira
plus tôt on veut prendre soin de sa
santé qu'on veut retrouver le goût la
saveur des aliments et pouvoir remplir
ses poumons d'air frais sans être gêné
dans son inspiration
on remplace une habitude par une autre
on remplace une mauvaise habitude par
une bonne et lorsqu'on fait le contraire
c'est à dire lorsqu'on perd une bonne
habitude là d'une manière ou d'une autre
c'est qu'on consent à perdre
cette bonne habitude on consent à
l'aller c'est être remplacée par une
mauvaise et c'est nous qui décidons
c'est par un effort d'inattention que
nous laissons disparaître une bonne
habitude nous la laissons se dissoudre
et être remplacé par une mauvaise mais
on sait très bien le cerveau réagit avec
beaucoup plus d'entrain lorsque vous lui
proposer quelque chose de positif plutôt
que lorsque vous lui proposez une
contrainte dire il faut que c'est le
meilleur moyen de créer un blocage
quelle que soit la suite de la phrase
d'ailleurs il faut que je prenne soin de
moi il faut que je travaille
il faut que je réussisse il faut il faut
il faut le il faut c'est la contrainte
la contrainte qui pèse sur nos têtes
c'est l'autorité l'autorité du surmoi
l'autorité de nos proches c'est la
pression du réel
bref c'est un impératif et l'impératif
n'est pas libérateur
remplacer une mauvaise habitude par une
bonne habitude c'est offrir à votre
cerveau l'opportunité d'être d'accord
avec votre décision et donc de faciliter
la mise en place de nouvelles habitudes
alors vous me direz c'est bien joli tout
simple mais concrètement comment mettre
en place de bonnes habitudes est entendu
que chacun voyant midi à sa porte
une bonne habitude c'est une bonne
habitude pour vous
selon vos objectifs vos rêves et vos
idéaux comment mettre en place de bonnes
habitudes
et bien tout simplement en cessant de
l'est mentaliser en cessant d'y
réfléchir
simplement le faisant je m'explique
s'astreindre à une discipline c'est
souvent associé à une volonté forte dira
que quelqu'un a de la volonté
lorsqu'il arrive à persister dans une
habitude contraignantes
ça peut être le sportif qui se lève tous
les matins pour faire sa séance
ça peut être l'écrivain qui va
s'infliger ses huit heures d'écriture
en réalité ça peut être tout ce que vous
voulez oui il faut la volonté
il faut une force de caractère
c'est indéniable mais prenons un autre
camp qui est tout simplement le cas du
réveil qui sonne
quand le réveil sonne ne m'attend pour
vous indiquer qu on vous attend au
bureau ou que vous commencez dans une
heure ou deux quand le réveil vous
signale vous devez sortir de votre lit
vous vous étiez si bien vous faire un
café prendre une douche et puis monter
dans la voiture pour aller bosser à ce
moment là vous ne vous posez pas la
question de l' envie du désir de la
motivation vous agissez en mode
automatique
vous faites ce que vous avez à faire
parce que vous savez que vous devez le
faire parce que vous l'avez fait hier et
que vous leur ferez demain que dieu
merci
vous aurez un jour de repos au bout de
quelques jours d'efforts je ne suis
évidemment pas en train de dire qu'il
faut étendre le concept du patronat sur
vous même mais quelque chose comme ça
soto dit
pinet c'est devenir son propre patron
c'est obéir à ses propres ordre et sait
faire ce que quand tu appelles
l'expérience de l'autonomie l'autonomie
littéralement c'est le fait de se
gouverner selon ses propres lois
d'autonomie s'opposa l'hétéronomie qui
et l'obéissance aux règles d'un autre
alors certes lorsque vous vous levez le
matin pour aller bosser pour un patron
vous êtes dans l'hétéronomie mais bon on
est tous plus ou moins dans
l'hétéronomie quand on n'a pas de patron
on a des clients
on a des factures on a des crédits mais
le fait est que si vous vous imposez la
même auto discipline pour vous mêmes que
dans votre travail bien à ce moment là
vous allez vivre quelque chose
d'intéressant qui est la fierté non pas
la fierté au sens ont de l'orgueil
on part la fierté mal placée mais la
fierté comme satisfaction qui résulte du
constat de ce qu'on a fait ce qu'on a
fait de bons pour nous on est toujours
fier d'avoir fait quelque chose de
bénéfique pour nous quelque chose de
constructif
quelque chose qu'on a envie de montrer
aux autres lorsque vous faites votre
première séance de sport
à la reprise vous êtes fiers de vous et
on dirait même que votre corps vous
remercie il vous exprime sa gratitude
c'est métaphorique bien
mais il ya quelque chose comme ça qui se
passe quand vous travaillez sur un
projet qui vous prend des jours des
nuits entières des semaines et que vous
avez terminé votre projet qu'ils aient
abouti au prix de vos efforts au prix de
votre auto discipline êtes fier et vous
savez que vous avez eu raison de vous
imposer ses habitudes et à linverse
lorsque vous échouez lorsque ça ne se
passe pas comme vous le souhaitiez et
que vous faites le constat de vos
négligences et à ce moment là vous avez
des regrets
vous avez de la culpabilité envers vous
même et non pas une culpabilité au sens
ce chrétien du terme mais une
culpabilité presque physique ont
conscience que ça dépend des deux vous
que malgré ça vous n'avez pas fait je
pense que tout le monde connaît ce
sentiment la force de l'habitude c'est
qu'elle nous dispense d'avoir à faire
des efforts et la volontée ce n'est rien
d'autre que le fruit de l'habitude de la
volonté se développe avec l'habitude de
prendre une image
on conduit une voiture on passe la
première on accélère on donne
l'impulsion aux véhicules premier
rapport de vitesse
c'est le plus puissant et lorsque la
voiture a pris sous l'impulsion
lorsqu'elle est lancée
le moteur commence à crier on le soulage
en passant la deuxième la deuxième on va
la pousser un petit peu et puis quand
elle aura fait son travail c'est la
troisième qui va prendre le relais et
lorsque vous arrivez en cinquième mais
vous avez l'impression quelque part que
c'est comme si vous étiez à l'arrêt
parce qu'il n'ya plus d'impulsion ya la
vitesse mais il n'ya plus d'impulsion
l'impulsion c'est le désir que vous avez
de mettre en place une bonne habitude et
la vitesse c'est ce que vous atteignez
lorsque la machine est lancée
lorsque vous n'avez plus besoin de
pousser
il en est des choses humaines comme il
en est des rapports de vitesse au début
il faut pousser l'habitude c'est
l'inertie c'est le mouvement qui se
perpétue grâce à l'impulsion de départ
en tout le boulot que vous avez à faire
c'est de maintenir l'habitude vouloir
en place une bonne habitude c'est être
animé d'un désir de changement
un désir d'amélioration de sa condition
sur tel ou tel point
leur envie de vous sentir plus en forme
une envie d'être plus efficace dans
votre travail une envie d'améliorer vos
relations sociales
c'est un désir qui vous pousse qui vous
donne l'impulsion
une fois que vous mettez en place les
conditions d'un changement à ce
moment-là vous entrez dans l'habitude
vous entrez dans la nécessité d'un
contrôle et d'une vigilance continue à
ce que vous faites pour vous maintenir
dans ce nouveau schéma
la volonté c'est ce qui vous permet de
rester dans ce schéma et cette volonté
et se nourrit des résultats que vous
aurez obtenu parce qu'une bonne habitude
a toujours des bons effets et les bons
effets vous rendront fier
cette fierté deviendra une énergie qui
vous permettra de maintenir votre
volonté vous avez remarqué comme on
prend souvent de nouvelles habitudes à
l'occasion d'un nouveau cycle les bonnes
résolutions du 1er janvier ou du jour de
l'anniversaire du jour de la rentrée
nous avons inconsciemment que l'habitude
est liée à la notion de cycle
et changer d'habitudes est beaucoup plus
facile quand on change de cycle parce
qu'on a cette impression de faire table
rase d'appuyer sur la touche reset a
l'impression d'être quelqu'un de neuf et
de lancer un nouveau programme
voyez le champ lexical que j'utilise
champ lexical très mécanique très
robotique
ça traduit assez bien ce qui se produit
en nous à travers le processus de
l'habitude une forme de mécanisation
mais ce n'est pas une mécanisation
déshumanisante
ce n'est pas une mécanisation qui nous
fait perdre notre âme si j'ose dire
c'est au contraire une mécanisation qui
tient compte du fait que nous sommes des
êtres physique et que par conséquent
nous sommes soumis aux lois de la
matière et la matière le monde physique
autour de nous et fonctionne à partir de
lois qui permettent de voir des
irrégularités imaginez ce que serait la
terre c'est à changer ses habitudes
orbital si elle décidé de faire une
pause au milieu de sa révolution
ce serait compliqué de ce point de vue
là nous n'échappons pas au règne
physique
nous sommes des êtres physique nous
sommes des êtres matériel nous sommes
soumis au temps à la gravité et à partir
de là il n'est pas absurde de ne
considérer que nous aussi nous pouvons
obéir à des lois cycliques nous pouvons
à l'occasion emprunter des
caractéristiques à tout ce qui est
mécanique
suivre des habitudes ne veut pas dire
être un robot suivre des habitudes veut
dire obéir à la loi
on s'est donné et ça il ya rien de plus
humain quand était un être un peu
ennuyeux très répétitif il avait le même
emploi du temps chaque jour se lever
tous les jours à 5h45 je crois il allait
faire sa promenade chronométrés
millimétré la légende raconte qui n'a
interrompu ses habitudes à deux
occasions à la révolution française et à
la publication d'un livre de rousseau
c'est déjà pas mal mais lorsque quand tu
parles de l'autonomie il n'a pas tort
parce que nul n'est plus esclave que
celui qui obéit à la tyrannie de ses
passions à la tyrannie de ses envies de
ses caprices éphémère et volatiles les
envies ses skis ne tiraille les envies
c'est ce qui nous empêche d'être serein
c'est ce qui crée comme diraient les
stoïciens les troubles de l'âme alors
que la volonté la volonté solide à
volonté ferme
c'est un gouvernail
et ce gouvernail permet aux bateaux dont
vous êtes le capitaine de ne pas se
laisser emporter par les courants de
l'envié et des passions garder cette
image à l'esprit vous êtes le capitaine
de votre vie et vous naviguez sur une
mer parfois clémente et parfois agités
c'est ce qui ne dépend pas de vous en
revanche c'est vous qui décidez de la
manière dont vous tenez la barre plus
vous aurez une profondeur de vue que
vous serez capable d'anticiper les
mouvements de l'eau plus vous saurez
vous y adapter mettre en place de bonnes
habitudes c'est limiter le risque de
vous laisser emporter par le courant
éventuellement d'être engloutis
l'habitude nous inscrire dans un rapport
cyclique à la vie et ce cycle donne du
sens donnent du sens parce que demain et
l'enfant d'aujourd'hui
les événements sont liés les uns aux
autres selon l'enchaînement de la
causalité même si tout ne dépend pas de
vous il dépend de vous d'agir sur ce qui
dépend de vous
changer d'habitude c'est prendre une
décision et la décision n'est pas un
processus mental
la décision c'est la fin de la réflexion
c'est le passage à l'acte c'est la
réalisation il n'y a pas cinquante
manière de passer à l'action
la seule manière de passer à l'action
cet passer à l'action
alors bien sûr à partir du moment où
vous allez mettre en place de nouvelles
habitudes il vous faudra faire preuve de
patience parce que les effets des bonnes
habitudes met un peu de temps avant de
se dévoiler et avant d'apparaître
clairement devant vous
les résultats de bonnes habitudes ne
sont jamais spectaculaire avec un peu de
patience vous verrez que ses effets vous
les aurez lorsque vous serez dans votre
vitesse de croisière lorsque vous aurez
donné l'impulsion que vous serez soutenu
par l'inertie
c'est à dire par votre volonté nourri de
la fierté nourrit la satisfaction mais à
vous repenserez à vos mauvaises
habitudes passées et vous vous
demanderez comment vous avez pu vous
confondre avec ses mauvaises habitudes
comment vous avez pu avoir cette seconde
nature paraît désormais si loin
c'est ça la force de l'habitude
et c'est ce que j'espère vous avoir
transmis aujourd'hui soyez sages
[Musique]
où